yeah I'm curious like going back to the
virginity thing if you guys could go
back in time would you wait until you
were married Tough sex yes yeah you
would 100 yes Courtney Barnes
um
do you know what I don't know because I
feel like every every relationship that
I've been in I've I've learned something
from so it's like if I said I'd go back
and change it and not do it then I
wouldn't learn I wouldn't have learned
the things that I wouldn't moving
forward so I don't know it's it's almost
like saying I'm just gonna eliminate
experiences that I've had
yeah but if they ended badly what value
does like sexual experience bring to you
now
like what you know if you're gonna let's
say you meet your husband tomorrow and
you're going into a marriage and you
could have just slept with him yeah or
slept with him and all these other guys
like don't you think it would be better
to just sleep with him I understand what
you're saying because obviously when you
get married the love that you have for
that person other people that you've
been in a relationship is definitely
different because you're married and
you're gonna build a life with them so I
think when I get to that I'll probably
be like oh do you know what I wish I
would have waited yeah now I haven't I'm
not trying to settle down I'm not in
that time of my life so my perspective
is going to be different what age would
you like to settle down
if I'm completely honest it's all about
when my career is is if one I'm happy
with where I am in my life if that makes
sense because I wouldn't want to settle
down not having achieved everything that
I want to achieve on myself because I'm
kind of quite selfish in that I want to
be very successful do a lot have tons of
businesses so I think so far I blew up
and I had all this success by the time I
was 27. then cool I'll I'll look for
when I'm 27 but I it depends on where I
am financially and stuff like that to be
honest what value does your career bring
to a guy
well music I want to inspire people and
motivate people and I want to make a
change I want to yeah a man don't care
like you said oh I'm looking for a girl
to inspire and motivate you know what I
mean yeah yeah 100 I think it's like
you're young now you're pretty now and
but you're going to be less pretty and
less young in 10 years and five years so
like why would you not look for that
when you're younger
I mean I look I look quite young now so
maybe when I'm older I'll still look
young I mean but um I just know what I
want out of life yes I I do want a
family for me that's very important
because I don't have any siblings and
all my family members are very far
spread out across the world so for me I
need that security so just just a stat
for you guys did you know if you hit 30
and you and you're still single you drop
to a less than 50 chance of you being
able to have a kid meaning that if
you're still single you're more likely
to not have a kid than have one
and so it's like knowing that you
wouldn't want like because you know
you're 24 now right yeah let's say you
date a guy tomorrow and you date him for
three years and it doesn't work out yeah
it's like then no no now you're a bit
older and you have to keep yeah I do
think everything happens for a reason
though if I'm completely honestly I
could turn 13 find my dream guy the next
day do you know what I mean and then
build a relationship with you you can't
you could but the odds aren't in your
favor yeah and the number and that's
what that's what I'm saying like I think
a lot of times Society tells us to go
after a career first when it would be a
lot easier if we if we were married
because you could have the same
experiences you could just have them
with your husband very true but then
what if he then wanted to have kids with
you straight away then you'd have to
sacrifice that and you want to be a
mother oh yeah I want like five kids you
know 90 of your ex 90 of your eggs are
gone by 30. yeah so wait wait too long
you can't have five
do you know when geriatric pregnancy
starts
well if you know the answer I was going
for them
so geriatric pregnancy is like high risk
pregnancy do you know when that starts
I'd probably say 30 30 plus well you
know it's 40 right no right you just
said it wrong
28 it's 35. really yeah so high risk
pregnancy starts at 35. and IVF it's
actually most likely that it won't work
out complications
I'm I'm IVF and I'm an IVF baby my
parents started um trying to have a kid
at 34 I think but I think they had
complications anyway yeah no and they're
lucky that you you yeah they're lucky
but that's not the norm like the
majority of IVF doesn't work out yeah
and there's complications as well so
yeah but we can do stuff like freeze our
eggs and stuff like that I know that
again it's it's not 100 but but like you
said no but but even like the odds are
if you're over it's like it's a less
than 50 chance that you that that works
out that you actually even conceive the
kid
so it's like they kind of lie to us
because they tell them you they tell us
we have all these options when we don't
when half of your options are also gone
by 30. so the number of options you have
at 20 by the time you get to 30 half of
them are gone don't you think it's a lot
of pressure on a woman yeah it is it's
actually quite sad like even this
conversation is opened my eyes and it
makes you realize you're being told some
people are saying that women shouldn't
have a career they should focus on their
marriage and care about their husband
and their children
um other people want to not have
Housewives and want their woman to have
a career but then we have the pressure
of not being able to have kids at a
certain age there's just there's so much
for women to kind of squeeze in yeah
well that's the thing you can't have
everything but it's like what outcomes
do you want like what priorities yeah
like what what outcomes would make you
happy everyone has a different
priorities right and so it's kind of a
trade-off because you know women over
the age of 45 that are still single and
childless like they're on drugs they're
on drugs at a higher rate than any other
group and they're more depressed than
any other group and they don't tell us
that we're really on a Time clock and
and they don't really warn us about that
and you just you can't have everything
and so it's the question of like what
outcome do you want personally for me
I've had this conversation myself a fair
few years ago actually
um I want the fame and fortune and to
have a career but I need a family right
for my mental health so if I had a pill
one of them was to have a family one of
them be famous I would have a family
because that's what I need right right
so why wouldn't you prioritize that now
knowing knowing that the quality of guy
you're gonna get is only going to get
worse like right now that you're the
most attractive you're ever gonna be you
know it'd be one thing if you were fat
and then you could lose weight and get
it but you're in shape right
because they always give me this
exception like because if you're fat duh
but but you know you're in good shape so
it's like this is the highest quality
guy you're ever going to be able to get
yeah and not it's only gonna get worse I
hear that but for me to raise a family
the way I want to raise it I want to
have money that's not for me to go spoil
my kids because I don't I think raisins
kids spoil doesn't teach them anything
but I would want them to not struggle
the way that I've struggled could you
marry a guy with money would I marry a
guy of course yeah yeah so why don't you
just do that because you could you're
pretty enough I mean thank you I could
do but I wouldn't be fulfilled and I
think in life it's all about fulfilling
your own hopes and dreams and stuff like
that so what is it like this dream this
world doesn't sound real to me and this
has come I come from like my dad's a top
like one percent earner he's very very
successful and like I grew up around
successful people but yeah this this
doesn't sound real where okay because
where the mom has this successful career
and the dad also has the successful
career and they also have they also have
five kids like Something's Gotta Give
you literally can't do everything or
you're paying a nanny to raise your kid
I mean to be fair I'm not gonna lie if I
had money and I was a businesswoman and
I was busy I would have help if I could
afford it I generally would have help
and that's not me saying I can't be
bothered to look after my children of
course but I would be there for the
important parts though say if I had it's
not the same I do understand where
you're coming from but that would be the
sacrifice that I would take and I would
want my kids to see a world right but
that's the problem that's the modern
mindset it's about my career and me
before the family and I think that's
like what what is so broken down
nowadays is that we all care about
ourselves before the family and and to
have a family that's successful you have
to be selfless you know our grandmothers
and our great-grandmothers didn't stay
with our husbands by thinking about
themselves yeah
because mothers put their child before
themselves when they have children when
they don't have children obviously you
should be thinking about that ahead of
time but I am doing by creating a career
for myself to provide for the family
that I wouldn't want so yeah you
mentioned you want to be a mother like
what are you doing to prepare to be a
mother
I eat healthy most of the time
um
that's a really good question actually
that's put me on the spot well my
daughter what are you doing so if a guy
said okay you can work for three years
he meets you today and he says okay
that's fine you're working you work for
three years and then we're gonna have
children what skills do you bring to the
table what would you say
I'm a very fair and understanding person
um I'm able to
oh gosh that's a really hard who's got
the most biggest heart oh thank you I'm
like I said I'm a really caring person
um I wouldn't I know what my parents did
that I would want to do different
um and yeah that's such a hard question
it put me on the spot there's a lot of
things but I just can't really think of
them
you're very ambitious as well Ashton
right right but that doesn't matter to a
guy that's ambitious like yeah and you
know I I'm ambitious but I don't give a
I don't care if I cared and I love
loved you I would do anything for you
like I would be your your support your
everything right but but why because you
know it's like if you're applying to a
job you say I can do this this and this
so
um I understand what like when you guys
were saying earlier what you because
it's all about status for a man and
their woman like for example if there
was a group of guys and all their
girlfriends were going out on a night
out and one of the guys turned around
and said well my woman's staying at home
in his head that's a status there it is
yeah for example for example if
um your mum was to bring his friends
around and you were to offer oh what
would you guys like to eat again that's
a status thing because your woman is
taking care of you and your friends so I
I want to provide which is where the
money comes from because I also think
guys deserve to be treated like a king
it's not just the girls should be wand
and dined all the time so that's why I
want to make money not just to be able
to take my husband out using his credit
card I want to use mine so your money is
his money in the relationship yeah okay
yeah 100 do you guys care about a girl's
money
easiest
Jonathan yeah so like if she needed
something and she has my kids you know
what I'm saying then I'll be obviously
offer it to her but my money is my money
I obviously give it to you if you need
it and your money is my money easier
that's what it was Jonathan yeah in a
marriage yeah because you come together
because like the girl's money is my
money and my money is my money Jonathan
but when she needs something obviously
provided for her Jonathan yeah yeah
that's exactly what I'm saying I still
see it as my money but I'm not gonna not
allow you to have it because we're
married we're a partnership
so much
thanks
do you care no I don't care at all and
any woman that's ever like done anything
with me no I pay for everything
five-star hotels restaurants I'm flying
to Poland tomorrow
her and her friend are supposed to meet
up with me she said we're not rich like
that I said whenever I ever had you pay
for anything you might find that I find
the offensive win again I find that
offensive one again
but isn't it rude if they don't though
no no it's not because you know who
especially you think it's offensive
friends split the ball they were like oh
my friend let me split the ball with you
but the offer though would you rather a
girl that's offensive that's offensive
end of do you know what I'm saying
to get used to the fact that because on
me the cash is on me tap it and love go
is that a way to go you know what I'm
saying no oh can I um split this with
you that's embarrassing for the moon do
not listen the man knows he has to pee
you know what I'm saying and the girl
should know to stand back let him handle
the finances easier you can't say to
your own man or can I offer can I split
the bill with you that's offensive
that's that that's that I was saying I'm
friends with you so I offer to Slit the
rule if you know he was truly your man
you would just leave it to him he'll pay
you this and that you don't think about
it you know what I'm saying do you think
of a guy except splitting the Bell he
doesn't like her that much then he's a
bro easy as in love okay as many
of you know I was just banned on Tic Tac
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thank
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible